by the way diets are safe to talk about
because there's no military backing
unless you mess with the vegans the
vegans they're like a militia
but you know what look i'm happy to talk
to vegans and carnivores and i don't do
either of those things but at the end of
the day
there is no nobody's going to force you
to do it so it's kind of safe
you know what i mean but but you could
get cancelled like was it
uh um um adele she didn't get cancelled
but they got really mad because she had
lost all this weight and
and again you know just for everybody
watching it's like i think i think a
core component of your podcast
has to do with your you know health and
wellness and weight loss transformation
stuff
for sure yes i i i think adele was a
hell of a lot more famous than me
so that's a tick against her for like
she's already
on more fragile footing um also i'm a
dude
and and we have to deal with that stress
in much different ways than gals do
and she was kind of uh you know and i
think i think it's really awesome
i i really like lizzo a lot and what
lizzo talks about
but i think adele meant something to a
lot of people so when she
stepped out of it it was crushing to
them
but i think adele should be able to do
whatever the hell heck adele wants
well i mentioned this to you uh before
the show that i knew people when i was
younger that were big fans of you you
know you're in these movies and you were
very
you know overweight is it or obese
whatever
yeah you can't defend me with those
words well
uh you know just for the truth you know
keep it keep it fresh i was
550 pounds so yeah i was morbidly
obese perhaps even more abundantly more
abundantly
that phrase um not it really just
like the pointing it out anyway but i
knew people when i was younger that were
fans of yours because you represented
them yeah they looked to the movies and
they finally saw
hey this person's like me and i think i
think that's really interesting
especially what you mentioned with adele
because it was probably the same thing
yeah a lot of young overweight women who
see that she's famous
and successful and talented and then she
sought to lose weight
probably because she wanted to be
healthier and take care of herself and
live longer and all of these things
make people feel bad i guess yeah i've
i've definitely had some people say i
preferred you fat um and
i just don't care like because i want to
be
the way i'm i i had been wanting to be
the size i am now for so long that like
how you want me to be doesn't really
matter and then i will say
uh the flip side is there are a ton of
people out there who
also have goals that maybe they haven't
achieved
that they look at me and go like i
wasn't even necessarily that heavy
and he did this maybe it's possible for
me too and that and that
feels good what was it the experience
like growing up like
how did it how did you find yourself to
become obese and then
what changed and how did you get to
where you are now well
interestingly enough when we um think
about this in
political terms and the idea of forcing
people to do things they don't want to
do
i was placed on diets starting at five
years old
wow and i i never wanted to be on a diet
at five i'd never wanted to be like the
moment
i woke up and when i want to be on a
diet i want to lose weight
was the first time in my life that diets
started working and i was
22 at that point but i was also 550
pounds
also it had nothing to do with health
like if that was not a metric i was
using
i uh you know sitting in this chair
when i was uh even today i come in
and i'm testing the chair like is this
chair gonna collapse under me
uh waking up every day with swollen sore
feet
you know having real knee issues
um sweating as i'm toweling off from a
shower that i had cool so i wouldn't
overheat like
these are the issues that i was like i'm
done doing that
health never entered into it and i was
very unhealthy
once i got my footing and i started to
become more healthy i went oh this is
this is really cool too now i'm gonna
apply this metric as
a goal and that's been something i put
but
i don't think any of it works if you're
if you're trying to force somebody to do
it so
there's a real weird conversation
happening right now in the world where
there is one team
going um obesity or
overweightness or whatever word is
appropriate is
not a metric in health and then there's
another team going
uh as a reaction to that almost you're
just lazy
um you need to lose weight and so
there's these two
bizarre battles um and i i personally
don't think either is right i think
we live in a day where there isn't a lot
of physical
um activity required
certainly we're not out hunting and
gathering food
uh even even the job that the the
workplace has
has gone down in as far as like physical
abilities
look at us sitting in chairs this is
your job this is amazing
you know and so at the same time
food has become cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and like
of course people are gonna get become
overweight this is like a perfect
uh confluence of events to lead to that
you know we're the wealthiest country of
all time ever
we have a lot of overweight people
because they're all kings and now they
close the gyms tell people to stay
inside and some countries even make sure
that they can't walk two blocks away
from where they live
right so a lot of insanity is happening
uh especially i think
the the conversation about health has
been hijacked by so many different
individuals by so many different special
interests
and there's so many different opinions
on there i think a lot of people have a
hard time finding out what's right for
them
but then also a lot of people forget
you're an individual individually what's
right for you
might not be right for someone else so
that's another big discussion
i think it's really interesting you
mentioned it's kind of like the
libertarian nature of it
like you've got to decide for yourself
people can't force you to do it you've
got to figure out what works for
yourself as well
yeah i don't think forcing people to do
anything is is is right it doesn't work
i mean yeah i don't think so either you
said moderate when i asked you earlier
said moderation was how you did what is
that exactly
you know at the end of the day all
almost all you know even if you're
even if you're not hyper focused on it
the principle behind
um diets is thermogenesis it's the
the way you use energy and so food is an
energy source for your body i've done
you know i'm just gonna eat 500 calories
a day
for two months and white knuckled my way
through it that's extreme
right taking an entire food group and
demonizing it and cutting it out of my
life that's also extreme
i at the end of the a few years ago i
found like if i just
spend some time counting calories
and figure out because i actually had no
idea
what my body required i would cut out
carbs
and then after a while i wouldn't lose
weight anymore because i was eating too
much
steaks and avocado and butter right and
then i would just have to start reducing
that
without thinking about it but i'm going
like if i want to lose weight i have to
eat less
and then i start losing weight again
which is kind of against the principle
of the keto diet
where you're supposed to just be full
from eating a bunch of fat
yeah but at the end of the day the way
your body consumes
excess fat is by feeding it too little
now if you go really extreme
the the vasts
the vast evidence is that you're gonna
relapse very few people go
very extreme do it very quickly and then
have
that as a sustainable achievement you
need to set a habit
you need to turn you need to create a
routine and then turn the routine into a
habit
and and the people who do like crash
diets and stuff they don't they're
forcing themselves
and then once they get to their desired
goal their habits return
so it's it's really about i think what
do they say it's like 21 days
you set a habit yes something like that
yeah and
and and you know the other thing is
um there's there's just uh there's just
a lot of
nuance in here i can also empathize with
the idea of like when you're ready to do
it and you wake up one day and you go oh
my god i can't
be this weight anymore it's hard to
breathe you know um
i'm sweating all the time my feet hurt
my back hurts
you want it fast you want you know as i
wanted it fast you want to get that
weight off as quick as possible
yeah it's very hard to like take a step
back and go this is going to take a lot
of time and a lot of hard work that's a
really hard proposition to make for
people
and also rewinding a lot of the kind of
establishment conditioning that's
brought on to people that starts off as
their children
in school if you look at a lot of the
school lunches they are
absolutely horrible for you if you look
at that food
triangle that the government recommends
for you it is absolutely horrible for
you if you look at a lot of the fat
that's being
uh banned and not used in large
supermarkets that's because of a sugar
industry banning it for you and then the
larger consequences of that are not even
talked about what do you see though is
you see a lot of mcdonald's commercials
you see pepsi commercials telling you to
get a covet
test you see government officials
telling you where masks social distance
but
that's it predominance where's the go
outside
yeah like go for a walk get some
exercise where's the sleep where's the
media
you know why i always wondered why it is
they put psychoactive stimulants in our
sodas
and i'm like it really is a sweet deal
for these fast food companies
you get a double a big mac with extra
sauce and an extra large super sized fry
or whatever
and then you eat it and it makes you
feel miserable so then you guzzle down
a half gallon of psycho of soda chock
full of psychoactive stimulants you
better be careful
be careful tim the the the thought
police are going to go after you for
attacking woca-cola now
be careful uh but but no i always i
remember when i was younger i'd be like
watching someone eat this is really
awful food
and they'll go oh i feel so i can't move
and then they would take the
the you know the two quart cup of coke
or pepsi and then chug it and be like
now i feel good i'm like yeah caffeine
is a stimulant
you're like you know what you know what
really blows my mind you guys ever see
those commercials
where it's like a really big fat guy and
he's like eating a giant pizza with his
friends and then he goes
and it's like do you have heartburn take
this drug and i'm like dude stop eating
the pizza it's like
it's it's hurting you yeah nonstop
commercials and all these other
supplements take that i remember being
in in kentucky once and seeing at a
diner this
morbidly a beast family and instead of
like regular like drinks you know like
regular drinks just
standing on their table they had those
huge soda bottles and they had an infant
baby
and the infant baby was obese too and
they were literally giving the baby
the woca cola like this baby i'm like
why i just i i lost a little bit of hope
and humanity yeah my hope is still there
i'm very optimistic but seeing that
seeing these
really large people feeding their child
just all the woke hold on hold on this
is
there's serious problems here i mean
what's what do you do you know michael
bloomberg
wanted to ban didn't he try to ban large
sodas or did he actually do it
in new york he banned he tried i don't
think he was successful you know
i have i can't say that i think any food
thing is bad i think it can be used in a
way that
goes against how you want it to act in
your body
but at the end of the day i think that's
up to us you know what i mean like we we
didn't
all out ban cigarettes other than san
francisco
but like they taxed the heck out of them
they bar
you can't go into buildings anymore with
cigarettes so they found a way
you know make it so you can't smoke yeah
i mean i guess it's because it's
unhealthy to
other people um but at the end of the
day
we still allow people to smoke you know
just gotta go in the park and not stand
near anybody
right and then you can have your
cigarette well everyone's vaping now too
and then they banned that
right i i don't think look there's a ron
paul video we referenced the other day
and it's just one of the greatest videos
ever did you see this
from 1988 oh it's just so good he there
he's talking about
the government shouldn't regulate drugs
because the government can't make you a
good person
you have to choose and then at the end
he's talking to some guy and he goes
he's like the government's not going to
make you a good person why does how
about the government puts you on a diet
you're a little overweight and then
everyone in the audience is like boo
boo and i'm like what he's making a good
point well but they also shouldn't maybe
shouldn't subsidize drugs like that
sugar industry the aspartame industry
and the hype
they're subsidized if there yeah if the
government's going to get involved
there's going to be an underground mafia
market of people selling
large sugary drinks everywhere
prohibition doesn't work it never did
work no matter what it is
every time government gets involved it
screws people over let's just be honest
with ourselves what we do need is
personal responsibility and not the
government intervening telling you
about food triangles that are absolutely
wrong not subsidizing and running with
big sugar industries and other
industries
not running with gmos and monsantos that
has a revolving door within the fda
maybe maybe without government we
wouldn't have so many people that
are so dependent on these chemicals it's
true but you've got to protect the kids
like we used to sell
cigarettes to kids there used to be like
joe camel the cartoon character the
government had to ban those because the
market wanted to get them hooked
early in the morning more importantly
there was medical doctors telling you to
smoke because it was good for your
health keep that baby
okay so keep that in mind especially
when you have medical doctors
now because medical doctors could be
bought and sold just like politicians
could be bought and sold and people need
to remember that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you